bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir la bataille pour les
postes stratégiques
à l'assemblée on s'attendait à ce
qu'elle soit rude finalement les députés
ont réussi à élire six nouveaux
vice-présidents et 3 nouveau questeur à
l'issue d'une après midi de vote un peu
moins tendue que prévu même si elle fait
des mécontents à gauche on le verra on
va tous vous d'expliquer des résultats
fruit d'intenses tractations entre
politique et arithmétique grand
décryptage dans un instant avec nos
invités le stade de france les terrasses
le bataclan c'est la pire attaque
terroriste commise sur le sol français
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 et à l'heure du verdict ce soir
plus de neuf mois d'audience des
centaines d'heures d'audition des
victimes des accusés par la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris un procès
peut-il servir de thérapie nous poserons
la question à de nos deux grands témoins
ce soir juliette mais adel ancien
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'aide aux
victimes et guillaume denoix de
saint-marc fondateur de l'association
française des victimes du terrorisme
enfin 2 a franchi ce soir deux partis
pris la 6 monologue mariette darrigrand
va retracer pour nous d'itinéraires du
mot compromis tout jamais dans l'air du
temps et puis le grand reporter vincent
du jeu nous parle de donald trump ce
soir un putschiste en liberté après un
nouveau témoignage accablant pour lui
sur l' attaque du capitole voilà pour le
menu ce soir tu es parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs ce sont des batailles en
général feutrée qui se joue à huis clos
mais la situation politique inédite à
l'assemblée a changé bien des usages on
va parler ce soir de la répartition des
postes clés au palais bourbon questeur
vice président secrétaire et demain
président de la commission des finances
très très convoité vous connaissez tous
à parker charles de courson bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous au
député réélu pour la septième fois
consécutive
je ne dis pas de bêtises dans votre
circonscription de la marne vous êtes un
centriste non macro nist est ce que ça
vous convient comme on peut le lire bon
et vous siégez dans un nouveau groupe à
l'assemblée alors le nom est compliqué
libertés indépendant outre-mer et
territoires qui compte seize députés
c'est l'ancien groupe liberté et
territoires on peut dire qu'aujourd'hui
bon eh bien je crois savoir aussi que
vous êtes officiellement candidat à la
présidence de la commission des finances
je confirme et et ben voilà c'est dit
vous avez beaucoup de choses à nous dire
ce soir parce que on a besoin de
comprendre comment t'est de ces
tractations se sont déroulées
aujourd'hui bonsoir aurait dû trouver
bonsoir merci d'être là nos visages de
l'assemblée député la france insoumise
de seine saint denis économiste de
formation vous comptez siéger dans la
commission des finances tiens je serai
dans la commission affaires économiques
à la mer parce que notre commission qui
s'occupe des questions économiques alors
justement on dire un mot du poste très
convoité de la commission des finances
bonsoir anne charlène bezina bonsoir
merci d'être là constitutionnaliste
maître de conférences en droit public à
l'université de rouen et à sciences po
paris mais on va commencer avec vous ce
soir et les amours d'un gars va bonsoir
vous avez tout suivi de cette journée de
vote dans l'hémicycle il y avait de la
tension et surtout beaucoup de tension à
l'extérieur vous allez tout nous
expliquer si j'ai bien compris qui était
lui à quel poste on voit ça tout de
suite
[Musique]
elsa à nouveau cet après midi
l'assemblée a pris les allures d'une
arène politique exactement c'était une
journée où il y avait de la coulisse des
coups de théâtre des accusations de
pacte entre la droite la majorité le
rassemblement national bref tous les
ingrédients pour une journée encore très
politique c'est l élection du bureau de
l'assemblée le bureau sont les vice
présidents les questeurs et les
secrétaires alors au départ c'est un
système assez technique on a un nombre
de points qu'on répartis
proportionnellement selon les groupes et
puis on essaye d'avoir un accord global
un groupe diège et deux points et demi
je peux prétendre à la questure un autre
avec ceux des points veut un poste de
vice président sauf qu'aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas eu d'accord global mais il
semblerait bien qu'il y ait eu des deals
est d accord un peu partiel notamment
sur la question des vice présidents
plusieurs groupes se sont accordés sur
une liste de six noms ça tombe bien il
ya six postes donc normalement le compte
est bon pas besoin de faire un vote sauf
que parmi ses vice présidents il y en
avait deux du rassemblement national et
que ça ne passe pas du tout pour les
écologistes et pour les insoumis qui ont
donc fait acte de deux candidatures
supplémentaires in extremis et ça a donc
déclenché un vote dans l'hémicycle alors
qui a été élu dans les six de départ
deux candidates pour la majorité elodie
jacquet la forge pour le modem naïma
mucho pour horizon deux députés de la
nuque au delà du ps valérie rabault pour
le ps et caroline tchatche et les
insoumis et donc les deux candidats du
r'n vous les voyez à l'image et la porte
et sébastien chenu sauf qu'ils ont été
élus avec 290 voix pour l'un 284 voix
pour l'autre c'est à dire bien plus que
les voix de leur groupe des députés des
républicains des députés de la majorité
ont bien voté pour des candidats rm
alors pour la présidente du groupe
renaissance aurore bergé il fallait bien
de toute façon que ce bureau reflètent
les différentes sensibilités écouter
aujourd'hui on a une assemblée qui
représente
l'ensemble des français et on doit
évidemment s'y conformer pour que nos
institutions puissent fonctionner quelle
serait l'image pour renverser
aujourd'hui nous avions écarter tous les
candidats en sommes-nous tous les
candidats et rennes où tous les
candidats aient l'air je crois que là on
aurait été lourdement sanctionné par les
français sait on à la positive le faire
peut faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
troisième tour qui fasse que la majorité
soit majoritaire mais c'est parce que
les français ont voulu donc c'est parce
que nous avons fait alors visiblement
dans la majorité les consignes n'étaient
pas tout à fait clair est-ce qu'il
fallait voter pour la liste des six
prévus au départ ou que pour les
candidats de son camp mais quand on fait
les comptes il ya bien des députés de la
majorité qui ont voté pour des candidats
et rennes et ça pour la nuque c'est une
complicité écoutez paul vannier c'est un
jour très grave aujourd'hui la macro ni
a décidé d'appuyer les candidats du
rassemblement national de l'extrême
droite qui accèdent à deux
vice-présidents si c'est un
franchissement de seuil qui est très
inquiétant une banalisation de l'extrême
droite
alors expliquez nous ce que ça pourrait
changer ça aurait pu changer ou pas le
résultat final ou pas pas forcément
parce que s'il n'y a pas de majorité
absolue au premier tour et au deuxième
tour on en fait un troisième avec une
majorité relative en plus il n'y avait
eu aucun représentant du rassemblement
national est bien le parti aurait pu
crier au scandale démocratique voire
même saisir le conseil constitutionnel
mais là en élisant des candidats et
rennes au premier tour on fait rentrer
le rassemblement national par la grande
porte se désolait des élus socialistes
on aurait pu les faire rentrer mais par
la petite porte n'est une autre élection
très importante qui s'est déroulé cet
après midi dans l'est mais 6 et celle
des questeurs trois questeurs exactement
les questeurs c'est un poste qui est
très très convoité plus que ce un des
vice présidences aucune dépense n'est
fait ici sans leur aval là oui on peut
clairement parler d'un accord entre la
majorité et l air parce qu'il y avait
une liste commune regarder ce sont à des
candidats insoumis qui nous ont montré
on avait un bulletin de vote avec les
deux candidats de la majorité est le
candidat de la droite soit on avait un
bulletin de vote de bastien la chaux
pour la nuque les trois premiers donc
marie gew nous eric woerth pour la
majorité et eric ciotti pour la droite
ont été élus et il reste encore
l'élection de douze secrétaires merci
c'était très clair j'ai tout compris
merci elsa alors charles de courson
comment vous regardez vous avez
l'expérience de ces tractations ils sont
toujours très convoité ces postes de
questeur aujourd'hui on a trois
questeurs aucun rassemblement national
aucun nutt du ps est ce que vous trouvez
ça normal au regard des poids respectifs
en nombre de députés de ces deux
formations non mais bon je fais partie
d'un petit groupe voilà on est très
libre oui et mais on participe
naturellement négociations qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
eric ciotti qui était le questeur
sortant puisque les deux autres ont été
battus aux élections bien donc ça porte
pas chance d'être questeur
eric ciotti tenait absolument à garder
son siège alors que c'est le quatrième
groupe et donc pu penser les techniques
il fallait que ce soit quelqu'un de la
france insoumise ou du rassemblement
national qui est le deuxième groupe oui
donc on peut voir là et donc les
républicains d'après ce qu'on m'a
raconté ont troqué le poste de questeur
contre on présente personnes en demande
personnes
comme vice-président et déjà vous
confirmer tout cela n'est jeune var
c'est un espèce de trop car on a n'a pas
présenté sa candidature à la vice
présidente exactement parce que la
majorité a fait planer le doute que
sinon les républicains n'aurait ni la
vice présidence ni la questure et la
droite avait absolument besoin des voix
de la majorité pour garder son poste de
questeur wimart les républicains fois
suis verse l'ex majorité puisqu'il ya
plus de majorité avait besoin
des voix des républicains pour sécuriser
l'élection parce que je rappelle que
historiquement quand il y avait une
majorité c'était 2 pour la majorité et
un pour l'opposition il ya eu une
exception en 1993 venez d'être élu
député où la majorité était tellement
écrasante ont été 460 les trois postes
de questeur ont été attribués à des
membres de la majorité ce qui n'était
pas sain d'ailleurs mais aurélie trouvé
il ya un tout sauf est la fille qui
s'est jouée dans fluide sans cette
élection tous on est venu parce que
c'est ça qui est plus vous avez quand
même deux vice-présidences alors je vais
je vais rentrer là dedans mais
permettez-moi d'abord de préciser je
suis une nouvelle députée donc je
découvre aussi tout ça j'étais avec des
étudiants il ya j'étais prof maître de
conférences comme vous il ya quelques
jours encore en économie voilà et avec
des étudiants que ça donc je découvre
voilà mais ça ne m'empêche pas d'en
tirer quand même dire qu'est ce que vous
des enseignements d'abord le premier
c'est que ben les républicains s'avère
finalement une opposition de pacotille
puisque ils présentent des candidats en
commun avec en marche ils font des dix
extra donc ça ne s'appelle pas une
réelle opposition et le rassemblement
national aussi s avère finalement une
opposition de pacotille puisqu'on voit
bien et vous l'avez très bien expliqué
qu'il ya eu impact en fait en train en
marche le rassemblement national et et
les républicains je vais pas revenir sur
tout ce que vous avez expliqué et puis
dernière chaude dès ce soir vous avez
deux vice-présidences comme le rn
dernière chose et l'eire n'a pas dit la
présidente c'est à dire sur la vie
sociale politique la vice présidence le
problème il est il est celui ci c'est
que nous faisons entrer enfin pas nous 1
ceux qui ont voté pour le rassemblement
national c'est-à-dire beaucoup de droite
puisqu'il ya beaucoup plus de votes que
de députés d'extrême droite beaucoup de
droite ont voté pour l'extrême droite et
font rentrer l'extra watts par la grande
porte comme vous l'avez dit donc c'est
ça le problème et plus globalement il y
a un problème aujourd'hui de
banalisation de l'extrême droite vous
entendez aurore bergé elle vous dit
finalement balle à gauche et l'écologie
c'est sur le même plan que l'extrême
droite pardon ou et où est l'esprit
républicain qui voudrait que l'extrême
droite on y voit un parti comme les
autres vous pensez qu'avec
89-88 je crois en 9 89 députés les
rassemblements le rassemblement national
n'avait pas
droit à un des postes clés questeur au
vice pré cités c'est une question
vraiment pas ce que vous pensez il dit
en tout cas je pars sujet d'années ont
jamais nous n'aurions me jamais un
bulletin de vote pour le rassemblement
national jamais je nous nous observons
que beaucoup de députés de droite ont
mis un bulletin pour l'extrême droite et
donc il ya une alliance de fait qui est
en train de se faire entre la droite et
l'extrême droite ce qui est extrêmement
grave du point de vue des valeurs
républicaines jamais jamais nous ne
ferons d'alliance avec le rassemblement
national qui puise ses origines dans des
idées racistes des idées sexistes qui
divise la population et la stigmatiser
nous refusons de considérer
l'extravagance a toujours été fait par
ailleurs dans l'arc républicain
nous refusons de le considérer comme un
parti comme un autre et ce qui vient de
se passer est extrêmement grave de ce
point de vue là and shine bezina on ne
fait pas nouveau en fait qu'il y ait des
désaccords qu'il y ait des tractations
entre différents groupes ce qui est
nouveau c'est la composition cette
assemblée deux vice-présidences
rassemblement national orga haut-fond de
de la pondération de la proportion de
députés envoyés dans chaque groupe est
ce que c'est normal ou pas selon j'ai
envie d'y égal à politique qui a son
rôle bien sûr dans un cénacle comme
celui de l'assemblée nationale et celui
du sénat et il ya le droit parlementaire
qui s'y appliquent et qui aide à
reprendre de la perspective parce que il
est ce droit parlementaire fixé par les
règlements des assemblées mais aussi par
la coutume la pratique par beaucoup de
choses qui se font un petit peu par l'
usage et lusage en plus du texte du
règlement de l'assemblée nationale que
je cite nommément qui dit la composition
des organes directeurs 1 on en a
seulement deux c'est le bureau et la
conférence des présidents mais la
conférence des présidents et les fait
obligatoirement par la composition du
bureau donc un vrai manque lui le bureau
à concrétiser c'est vraiment comme le
gouvernement anglais un vieux le coeur
battait quand on sait tous ce qui permet
de gérer les finances de cette assemblée
son fonctionnement interne mais aussi la
tenue des débats 1 donc on est dans le
travail législatif et d'un travail
administratif d'une assemblée qui
fonctionne et bien tout cela doit je
cite c'est forcé deux
représentaient les représenter recolorer
bien ses forces et ses forces et france
2 manifestez donc les différentes
couleurs politiques au sein d'assemblées
ses forces et ça signifie quand même que
il faut qu'ils aient des efforts qu'ils
soient faits et donc des tractations et
c'est pour ça que ce système de point
d'ailleurs on en parle très complexe il
existe seulement depuis 2009 et qui a
volé en éclats puisque
ce matin skipper de la réunion du même
si finalement il est là sans être là
puisque c'est par tractations que les
choses se sont faites sans qu'on en
arrive au point a été obligé d'en
arriver au scrutin mais on en arrive
quand même avec des cooptations pour que
chacun est une représentation la juste
représentation
elle correspond quand même au cénacle de
l'assemblée c'est à dire que quand vous
avez un groupe rassemblement national
alors dont idéologiquement on sait qu'on
a toujours pour ce parti et vous dresser
un cordon sanitaire qui c'est vrai
structure le débat politique depuis
longtemps mais un groupe de 89 députés
techniquement si on s'efforce de
représenter au mieux la diversité de la
composition on ne peut pas faire comme
s'il n'existait pas et au sein de
l'assemblée on a coutume aussi de ne pas
voter l'un par rapport à l'autre ou l'un
contre l'autre ou une égard à des
considérations partisanes même si je
changeais lisent beaucoup puisque
évidemment la politique à son à son rôle
mais l'idée quand même lorsqu'on dirige
lorsqu'on est dans le bureau dans les
vice présidences dans les questeurs
c'est qu'on arrive à un certain sport
dans la manière dont on va travailler et
donc chacun concède à l'autre alors
c'est très présente et sir charles de
courson vous qui avez l'expérience de la
vie parlementaire expliquez nous
pourquoi les républicains ont préféré la
questure à une vice présidence pourquoi
c'est si stratégique les cordons de la
bourse qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce poste là pour bien comprendre mais
parce qu'eric ciotti tenait absolument à
rester quels sont les prérogatives de
kelly d'albi c'est la gestion de
l'assemblée nationale alors je vais vous
dire alors les questeurs faut mettre
tout sur la table
ils ont une majoration de leurs
indemnités de 5400 euros par mois ce qui
n'est quand même pas tout à fait
négligeable donc certain si vous voulez
salive comme on dit pour devenir
testeurs bien il ya deuxièmement ils ont
ils sont 60 % de plus par rapport aux
autres quoi pour faire ça c'est ça qui
m'a dit non mais attendez
deuxièmement ils ont un certain nombre
de moyens ils ont chacun un appartement
que le d'ailleurs en général ils
n'accusent pas un mais qui met à
disposition
des collègues de leur groupe ou pas
forcément uniquement de leur groupe
d'ailleurs et est donc ça facilite voilà
les bonnes relations et quand vous avez
un groupe
qui vient de votre circonscription pour
visiter l'assemblée nationale va vous
appeler l'un des questeurs et du moment
je vais t'arranger savait que ces
ravageurs ce que vous êtes en train de
dire pour les gens qui nous regardent
pour la vérité mais attendez il faut
dire la vérité la vérité c'est pas les
questeurs le poids politique des
questeurs n'est pas n'est pas important
dans le fonctionnement ce qui est
beaucoup plus important c'est de prison
la commission et surtout les rapporteurs
tech spartak général du budget pour la
commission des finances où le rapporteur
général sur la loi de financement et les
sociale ça c'est des postes mais quand
on se regarde quand même sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement pourquoi pas
investir dans l'immobilier
sinon la politique c'est aurélie trouvé
ça a été dit il ya aussi un usage qui
fait que ça montre aussi la juste
représentation ce qui ressort du vote
des français or ce qui se passe là sur
les trois postes de questure en gros
nous avons en marche en marche les
républicains donc ça veut dire quand
même que la première force d'opposition
va rappeler un les noms des trois
caisses joueurs monde et marie-eve nous
nous élançons rapporte eric ciotti on
peut même dire que certains l'ont
constaté un mari gew nous vient de la
droite eric woerth aussi très récemment
eric ciotti est encore à droite donc
mais juste pour vous dire une chose
c'est que la première force d'opposition
dans cette assemblée nationale c'est la
nuque ce qui à 151 députés qui avait un
candidat commun bastien la chaux et que
tout a été fait pour que la première
force d'opposition ne soient pas
représentés dans la question et c'est ça
le vrai problème c'est qu'en fait on y
de ce fait là le vote des français le
fait qu'ils aient cette première force
d'opposition sion aujourd'hui dans
l'assemblée nationale donc combien de
temps ils vont ils vont essayer de nier
le vote des français est de nier le fait
que nous sommes la première force
d'opposition
c'est alex confiance est en avance sur
la commune n'y a pas il n'y a pas un
groupe ne pèse 100 mégas une des camps
un candidat commun ne sais pas qui font
que j'aime pas couper ma chair jaune
collègues je vous ai pas coupé alesi
donc ya pas de groupes parlementaires du
ps il ya quatre groupes oui quel est
votre groupe et les filles 1 a je crois
74 c'est ça 75 74 75 et le front
national à 89 sièges dans la tradition
républicaine
c'était le deuxième groupe
membres en plus de l'opposition qui
avaient le troisième poste de questeur
je vous dis la tradition républicaine
voilà ce n'est qu'une tradition il ya
des système par points avec des
candidatures communes c'est justement on
a essayé de monter l'histoire des
groupes comme étant ce qui ce qui fait
que quelques qu'une force et le premier
est la première force d'opposition en
réalité c'est la capacité d'avoir des
candidatures communes d'avoir surtout
des votes en commun et de fait on a une
chance aujourd'hui n'en déplaise à nos
adversaires politiques n'en déplaise à
la droite et l'extrême nous avons une
gauche et une écologie réunis dans la
nuque ce qui fonctionne aujourd'hui avec
650 mesure en commun qui est prête à se
faire vous savez bien vous savez bien
que ce n'est pas vrai puisque vos trois
partenaires les trois autres groupes
issus de nu ps ont refusé le groupe
commun voyez donc votre argumentaire ne
tient pas et pourquoi alors je sais
c'est facile on va d'un coup pas mal
chers collègues j'ai commencé à
apprendre à respecter les autres elle
est terminée s'cusez moi la deuxième oui
on est pareil vous énerver autant on est
calme non vous n'êtes pas cap puisque
vous me couper sans arrêt à l'isie mme
deuxième observation chers jeunes
collègues qui apprendra un peu le
fonctionnement de cette maison mais
pressée que vous avez eu vos quatre
groupes n'ont pas toujours eu des
candidats communs voilà par exemple vos
collègues écologistes ont déposé des
candidatures séparées
voilà donc vous ne pouvez pas dire que
les nus pas c'est un groupe
parlementaire ce n'est pas morte enfin
on a avancé
mais pas du tout méprisant avec vos
histoires d'ajax excusez moi je suis
fier dans notre groupe d'avoir beaucoup
de jeunes qui viennent qui viennent
d'une diversité de métiers comme le mien
et qui sommes des équipes et nous sommes
effectivement nouveau dans l'assemblée
et fort heureusement nous nous laisse au
personnel politique dans l'essonne
cherchons énormément de nouveaux
rédacteurs du monde voilà une expérience
sur ce plateau et je renouvelle mes
vielles souhait de la police ce sont les
causes sont là et puis ensuite on passe
à la commission des finances qui m'ont
c'est vrai qu'il peut s'étonner qu'ils
viennent et des candidats écologistes
qui se soit présenté on s'est rendu
compte d'ailleurs certains n'avaient pas
voté pour eux mêmes voilà eux mêmes ont
l'habitude de poser leur candidature non
pas pour gagner ni même pour recueillir
les voix de leurs collègues de la nuque
mais simplement pour dire nous offrons
par nos deux candidatures une
alternative à la majorité si la majorité
ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait de vice
président du rassemblement national ils
ont à leur disposition ces deux
candidatures en revanche alors vous avez
sûrement de contredire mais on voit bien
quand même par leur score à la fin et
par notamment ce qu'on nous dit que tout
le monde n'était pas tout à fait au
clair sur ces deux candidates fait
recette les cendres et de rousseau et
benjamin le kazakh te ment sont les
aiglons ont certains on était peut-être
un peu mis au pied du mur certains
partenaires qui pour eux considéré que
comme il y avait les deux candidates
pour la vice-présidente de la nuque
valérie rabault et caroline fiat qui
était dans le premier accord pour eux
ils se sont dit bah voilà en fait on a
eu ce qu'on a voulu pas besoin d'aller
au vote bon je pense qu'on a fait le
tour pour les arcanes dans les coulisses
puisque tout s'est passé un peu salon de
la croix il faut le savoir c'est le
périmètre créé dans lequel des
journalistes n'ont pas le droit d'aller
où on peut croiser parfois des attelages
un peu baroque un ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement qui
travaillent qui travaillent ou qui
discute avec un républicain ou pourquoi
pas même un insoumis qui c'est qui pour
la commission des finances alors ça
c'est le poste le plus convoité
d'élections aura lieu demain et elle
promet d'être âpre pour le moins le
rassemblement national et la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale se
disputent le poste on va faire le point
avec kaiser je vous donne la parole
juste après
qui présidera la prestigieuse commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
depuis la réforme du règlement sous le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy ce poste
stratégique revient à un député de
l'opposition et jusqu'à présent la règle
s'appliquait sans difficulté
quand la droite était au pouvoir entre
2007 et 2012 deux socialistes l'ont
président et didier migaud puis jérôme
cahuzac sous le gouvernement de françois
hollande c'est gilles carez qui a occupé
le poste et lors de la précédente
législature
eric woerth qui siégeait alors sur les
bords des républicains mais aujourd'hui
la donne a changé
deux formations revendique le statut de
première force d'opposition la nuque qui
présente la candidature unique d'eric
coquerel mais aussi le rassemblement
national et ses 89 députés la majorité a
décidé de se tenir à l'écart de la
bataille elle ne participera pas au vote
ce sont donc les députés aient l'air qui
devraient jouer les arbitres je ne vois
pas trop l'intérêt pour les républicains
de faire la courte échelle un président
qui serait issu du rassemblement
national je vois pas les intérêts
politiques et puis je sais que certains
d'entre eux avec qui j'ai travaillé en
tout cas on a on était ensemble pendant
cinq ans la même commission et autres je
ne les vois pas avoir les mêmes valeurs
le résultat est entre les mains des
députés m si j'étais dans la situation
de l air ces exercices j'avais le choix
entre un président de la commission des
finances l air et un prix et monsieur
coquerel de la france insoumise je
n'hésiterai pas une demi-seconde à élire
le président de la commission ait l'air
le poste est stratégique
la commission des finances contrôler le
budget de l'état son président peut
avoir accès aux dossiers fiscaux
d'entreprises et de particuliers en 2009
le socialiste didier migaud s'était fait
communiquer la liste des contribuables
français détenant un compte en suisse
les membres de la commission des
finances vote jeudi à bulletin secret
fin du suspense en fin de matinée
anne-charlotte bezina là on est à la
fois dans le droit mais on est aussi
beaucoup dans la politique si on regarde
arithmétiquement on se dit a priori
puisque la majorité ensemble ne
participera pas à ce vote important
demain la première ministre l'a dit ça
devrait revenir à celui qu'elle plus de
députés c'est-à-dire la coalition de
gauche las nubes
qu'est ce que va faire qu'est ce que
vont faire les républicains qui ont je
le rappelle on va voir sur le camembert
tous les candidats qui se présentent un
candidat donc a priori au premier tour
chacun de voter pour son candidat c'est
véronique louwagie mais quand on voit la
stratégie du rassemblement national
marine le pen qui dit à longueur
d'interviews encore une dans le figaro
aujourd'hui une opposition de principe
serait stupide nous allons jouer le jeu
des institutions respectées le parlement
est il possible qu'on ait des surprises
demain et que la présidence revienne au
rassemblement national alors déjà il ya
beaucoup de choses à dire sur justement
ces règles de composition et leur valeur
et quitter parce que déjà tout à l'heure
on a parlé des vice-présidents du
questeur des questeurs on n'a pas parlé
et puisqu'ils sont pas encore élu des
secrétaires et de la présidence de
l'assemblée mais quand on parlait du
décompte de points normalement en fait
toute cette représentation équitable
devait être faite surtout ce paquet
d'accords donc il n'y a pas une
représentation équitable par questeur
une représentation équitable pour les
secrétaires une représentation c'est
pour tous d'accord hélas pour la
commission des finances
notre vrai problème c'est qu'en réalité
sous la vème république on avait
l'habitude entre une majorité et une
opposition et là on a de multiples
oppositions donc la manière dont ces
oppositions vont se structurer et vont
justement travailler ou non lui avec ont
l'une contre l'autre va être
déterminante demain notamment pour dire
comment on va gouverner alors
techniquement malheureusement
l'assemblée nationale ne connaît pas les
intergroupes et ne connaît pas même en
cas de candidature unique la nuque
puisque l'assemblée nationale ne connaît
que les différents groupes puisque
justement c'est pour ça qu'il y à
différents groupes puisque c'est comme
ça qu'on attribue les toits parole c'est
comme ça qu'on attribue les financements
c'est comme ça qu'on attribue les
amendements les prises de parole de
groupe et donc il y a tout intérêt pour
ces différents groupes à être
différenciées d'accord donc savane et
vous comment se déroule le mode de
scrutin pour être très clair c'est comme
pour la lecture la présence de
l'assemblée vous avez les membres de la
commission des finances qui élisent et
ya deux tours 3 tours comment ça se
passe some 73
l'ex majorité on va l'appeler
l'ex-majorité à 32 voix
la coalition du poste puisqu'il ya un
candidat commun à eric coquerel à 20
voix
le front national en a onze les
républicains 8
voilà et notre groupe 2 voilà donc vous
voyez ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
c'est que le républicain j'entendais
madame le pen dire il faut que les
républicains à votre bruma même si votre
bruce a fait 19 20 il suffit pas il faut
qu' il faudrait que c'est tout tous les
groupes ses premiers tours au premier
tour c'est la majorité absolue des
exprimés
les exprime autant d abstention et donc
oui non mais c'est pour ça que c'est un
peu subtil donc comme les oppositions
sont 20 plus 11 + 8 + 2 c'est-à-dire 31
de mémoire et bien 41 pardon 41 il faut
donc 22 voix pour passer au premier au
second tour
je vois que j'étais le dernier son
calcul attendez c'est
mathématique vous espérez quoi et donc
tout se passera en tête si vous voulez
mon sentiment tout se passera au
troisième tour et c'est la majorité
relative à l'activité relative celui qui
a le plus de voix est élu comment vous
voyez ce vote vous vous même vous êtes
candidat pour quelles raisons vous allez
très peu de chances d'être élu pour la
raison que je viens de vous évoquez nous
nous sommes des jambes des rêves à nous
sommes dans une opposition nous sommes
des gens ouverts en opposition
constructive
et est donc si nous nous présentions pas
et c'est notre fusion comme l'actuel
majeur ex majorité eh bien ça pouvait se
passer au premier tour puisque à ce
moment là il n'y aurait plus
quarante et un vote en mai 39 vous me
suivez oui oui du scellement mais ça
arrive il suffit de faire 20 voir s il
ya 39 votants puisque c'est pas la
majorité hostiles et les votants s'il a
fait baisser le seuil de la majorité
absolue a décidé de présenter un
candidat aurélie trouvé qu'est ce que
vous dites ce soir à vos collègues
voilà vos adversaires qu'ils soient
issus alors l'ex majorité c'est le mot
qu'utilisent charles de courson enfin le
groupe ensemble qui ne participera pas
au vote ou même les l air pour vous ce
serait incompréhensible que
arithmétiquement vous n'arriviez pas en
tête bien sûr on assez confiant en
réalité puisque fin si tu vois là aussi
d'abord le eric coquerel l'a dit les
députés un certain nombre de députés
l'air l'ont vu travailler aussi c'est
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement compétent
qui travaillent sur le budget dans la
commission finances depuis cinq ans pour
ma part je le connais très bien parce
qu'il est aussi député de
seine-saint-denis où je suis député
également et je crois que ce serait un
symbole aussi important que bien député
du du département le plus pauvre de la
zone mais qu'il a menée alors qu'on
aurait pu parler des femmes ça aurait pu
être à nouveau une candidate non mais on
a du mal à comprendre répond je crois
pourquoi pourquoi valérie rabault n'a
pas été préféré à eric coquerel valérie
rabault de tous les bords politiques
elle est experte des finances publiques
a eu des discussions est incontestée
enfin s'est même emballé c'est marrant
comme un depuis en fait plusieurs gens
d'affaires les décisions de lannux à la
place de lannux en fait nous avons eu
des décisions qui ont été d'ailleurs
très sereine qui ont amené alors qu'elle
est
c'est que londres en otage l'ensemble
mais comme ça a été dit en fait c'est
l'ensemble des postes qui compte donc
évidemment nous avons travaillé sur
l'ensemble des postes et nous sommes
arrivés à cet accord de manière
relativement sereine en réalité parce
qu'aussi tout le monde s'accorde sur la
qualité de la candidature
connaît-il autant que
je peux vous dire aussi qu'il ya le
d'abord ici connaître depuis cinq ans il
travaille de façon très âpre dans cette
commission des finances et en plus il ya
le symbole pour moi en tout cas je le
dis de la seine saint denis qui est un
département qui subit aussi des budgets
d'austérité qui subit aussi des budgets
qui ne donne pas assez par exemple pour
les services publics l'éducation je peux
vous dire que nous sommes les premières
victimes de ce type de voile à de
décision et je trouve ça important de
faire vivre de faire vivre aussi ces
différences de deux points de vue et
donc d'avoir une candidature est un
président de la commission des finances
est rude je le dis aussi les enverrais
coquerel yao c'est quand même une quand
même un enjeu qui est vous l'avez bien
expliqué qui est de pouvoir aussi avoir
un regard et avoir accès des
informations fiscales sur les
entreprises et que ça je le dis quand
même le fait de donner au rassemblement
national la présidence de la commission
des finances d'une à une force qui par
ailleurs est quand même proche de
certaines forces étrangères je vois là
vous aurez compris lesquels moi je pense
que ça pose aussi une question de
souveraineté nationale donc je dis je
dis vrai nom soit beaucoup de choses
vous a entendu soyons voilà soyons
raisonnables je voudrais marche des
cochons et anne-charlotte business tout
de suite mais un point de coulisses est
ce que c'est vrai que ces derniers jours
on s'est rendu compte est là que la
majorité
présidentielle l'ex majorité
qui ne prendra pas part au vote redoute
ça on peut le dire ce soir clairement
redoutent que la france a soumise ne
l'emportent oui alors que vous diront
qu'ils gagnent quand même la majorité
ils sont pas la majorité absolue la
bonne majorité relative existe open
majorité relative alors joron on
vérifiera n'existe pas pour vous dire
jusque sur effectivement cette
commission des finances de toute façon
le sort a été tranchée par elisabeth
baume puisque la première ministre l'a
redit les députés ne prendront pas part
au vote donc prendre part au vote ce
serait des dires la première ministre on
y jean mal comment ça peut se passer
même si vous dites effectivement après
jusqu'au moment du vote à l'initiative
de sa vue changé mais je crois que
certains en tout cas dans la majorité
n'ont pas envie de choisir ni entre le
rassemblement national ni entre eric
coquerel et que peut-être que cette
règle ne prendra pas part au vote les
arrange finalement en disant non au
moins on laisse les oppositions se
débrouiller choisir entre elles comme
c'est la tradition comme celle usages et
en même temps ça leur permet à eux de ne
pas aller dans un scrutin à une certaine
bezina puis vous aurez le mot de la fin
à charles de courson oui déjà c'est la
tradition en effet pour la majorité de
ne pas choisir son opposition ce qui
serait quand même un petit peu un petit
peu dangereux pour pour l'expression la
démocratie même si ici on est dans des
circonstances qui apparaissent assez
exceptionnel je dois ajouter quand même
que on entend beaucoup ces derniers
temps ce pouvoir d'avoir accès au
dossier frisco de chacun des individus
on élevait des shrek 4 1 il faut bien
savoir que cette commission des finances
elle est elle même encadrée elle a
encore un par le droit et que c'est
uniquement dans le cadre des budgets et
uniquement dans le cadre des
vérifications et uniquement dans le
cadre de la mission et d'égaliser sur un
contrôle que ces éléments sont possibles
et c'est pas un pouvoir propre du
président de la commission qui sera
dégainer comme ça rassure on les
français évidemment un ce est d'ailleurs
sur la présidence de cette commission
des finances on parle beaucoup parce que
c'est vrai que c'est un poste
stratégique mais il faut quand même
rappeler aussi que la commission des
finances est elle-même un organe de
l'assemblée nationale et que au sein de
l'assemblée on a l'habitude de
travailler de manière courtoise
républicaine et que je crois finalement
que la politique va être enfermé alors
par la pratique et que c'est de
relativiser un peu
l'enjeu voilà sachant que c'est le
rapporteur du budget qui sait le
rapporteur du budget les voter même si
ce n'est plus ou moins par le
gouvernement qui travaille en allez on
vous avez le mois de la fin de course en
excuser moi les pouvoirs d'investigation
un ancien gros pièces et sur place sont
les mêmes pour le rapporteur général et
pour le président de la commission des
finances ce qui a traumatisé la
commission des finances pour ceux qui
sont depuis aussi su depuis 29 ans c'est
ce qu'a fait jérôme cahuzac
jérôme cahuzac allez voir des dossiers
personnels et des dossiers d'entreprises
et c'est même un collègue socialiste
député qui m'a dit qu'ils utilisaient
pour les faire chanter
voilà ça c'est grave parce que ça c'est
grave
ils ont pour des gens reproduisent la
gestion attendait c'est possible
techniquement ce qui est interdit c'est
que une fois qu'il l'a fait il doit
garder le secret ce qui n'a pas été fait
par jérôme cahuzac et donc
beaucoup de gens ont peur et on peut
parler de juste titre pour vous ou pas
ont peur des accidents faut cela dit
donc à aucun contrôle ya trop de choses
entendues aucun il ya des pouvoirs
propres mais qui sont dans le cadre à
nombre de 7,90 vous pouvez aller au
ministère il allait
s'il voulait il ya des pouvoirs propres
manières du président de la commission
des finances c'est l'article 40 c'est à
dire d'apprécier la recevabilité des
amendements ce qui est parfois un
exercice délicat mais qui parfois peut
faire basculer telle ou telle chose il
ya ces pouvoirs propres d'investigation
comme le rapporteur général
et vous êtes tenus par le secret fiscal
mais on peut faire fuiter qu'un cette
journaliste comment on fait voilà donc
il faut être très vous mettez en garde
sur la personne qui sera choisie par le
suffrage des membres de la commission
vous êtes sûrs d'être aussi candidat on
chante compris merci beaucoup rendez
vous sur lcp demain matin on va suivre
ça ensemble minute par minute vous avez
compris à quel point il y a il est
dangereux autour de cette présidence
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu sur le
plateau de cp on va accueillir à présent
deux grands témoins juliette mais adel
ancien secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'aide aux victimes et guillaume denoix
de saint-marc fondateur de l'association
des victimes de terrorisme ce soir vous
le savez la cour spéciale d'assises de
paris va rendre le verdict dans le
procès hors norme des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 alors quelle est la place
d'un procès dans le processus de
reconstruction des victimes peut-il
servir de thérapie on a pas mal de
questions à poser à nos deux invités
comme les skis ce sujet signé marion
dakar
[Musique]
si on vous invite juliette mais adel
c'est parce que vous avez été secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'aide aux victimes
trois mois après les attentats du 15
novembre
françois hollande vous appelle au
gouvernement pour corriger les
dysfonctionnements de cette aide aux
victimes pour le responsable politique
que je suis il était évidemment
indispensable de dire que cette blessure
psychologique doit être reconnue et que
le préjudice doit être intégralement
indemnisés
on vous invite ce soir avec guillaume
denoix de saint marc directeur et
fondateur de l'association française des
victimes du terrorisme
vous avez perdu votre père dans
l'attentât contre le dc10 d'uta en 1989
et depuis vous accompagner les victimes
et vous avez vu l'évolution de leur
prise en charge
aujourd'hui le système français même
s'il ya encore des défauts et des
améliorations apportées et celui qui est
le plus efficace au monde et c'est sans
doute à cause des événements du 13
novembre qui a eu une remise à plat tout
le système d'accompagnement des victimes
du terrorisme d'une part mais qui a mené
aussi à une vraie politique
d'accompagnement des victimes en général
alors si on vous invite tous les deux ce
soir c'est parce que c'est aujourd'hui
le jour du verdict du procès hors norme
des attentats du 13 novembre
plus de 2500 victimes se sont
constituées parties civiles
415 ont témoigné à la barre elles ont
livré le récit de cette terrible soirée
et de l' après leurs blessures le stress
post traumatique c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'était un moment fort
mais les larmes ils sont un peu moins en
irak quand elles sont partagées et qu'on
peut se soutenir les uns les autres à
se tenir les uns les autres c'est paul
et
être écouté par la justice c'était pour
beaucoup une étape essentielle un procès
dont personne ne sortira indemne mais on
vous pose la question juliette mais adel
et guillaume denoix de saint marc une
fois la justice rendue comment
accompagner les victimes de terrorisme
bonsoir juliette mais adel et bonsoir
guillaume denoix de saint marc des
choses ont été faites pour accompagner
les victimes et là on est dans un cas
très particulier on est frappé toutes
les victimes
redoutent la fin du procès cette espèce
de vie de cette espèce de gouffre où
elles ne vont plus être ensemble ou la
solitude reviendra qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour elle est ce qu'il existe
quelque chose dans ce cas de figure
particulier d'abord il ya des
associations qui ont été très actives je
pense leifer parisse je pense à son
président je pense à tous ces
responsables associatifs qui ont été
présents pendant ces 10 mois et qui ont
créé des liens d'amitié et je crois
qu'au fond pour faire face à ce qui va
se passer après le procès se vide que
vous décriviez très bien et bien c'est
de la solidarité
d'abord associative humaine et puis
aussi n'oublions pas que l'état a un
rôle très important à jouer dans cet
accompagnement puis ce retour à une vie
aussi normale que possible alors comment
c'est quoi cet accompagnement post on
parle beaucoup de l'indemnisation on va
en parler il ya eu un secrétariat d'état
donc il n'existe plus aujourd'hui mais
c'est une politique interministérielle
mais au delà des sous pour le dire
clairement oui l'accompagnement alors
quoi justifier toute la politique
publique qui a été mise en place et pour
lequel a beaucoup construit et
travailler ensemble c'est justement de
sortir que de l'aspect que indemnitaire
c'est dire que la seule réponse de
l'état était indemnitaire et donc
forcément c'est insuffisant pour
accompagner des victimes notamment des
victimes du terrorisme et donc toute une
politique a été créé au départ pour les
digues multirisques elle peut être
étendue ensuite aux autres victimes et
ça j'en suis en tant que victime
terrisse très très fier parce que c'est
on a été précurseur on a amené l'état à
prendre ses responsabilités
et il ya eu des personnes comme comme
jette mais adele qui ont vraiment qu'on
construit avec nous en partant du besoin
des victimes et le besoin n'est pas le
même juste après l'attentât que dix ans
après aucun moment du procès qui est
entre les deux et je dirais même cet
accompagnement peut avoir continué sur
20 ans sur 30 ans mais de façon
complètement différente
il ya des étapes la première étape c'est
celle du deuil
et c'est l'immédiateté là on n'est plus
dans une urgence et ensuite dans un
accompagnement ensuite il ya eu quelque
chose qui autre chose qui se passe une
fois qu'on a enterré ceux qui sont morts
puis il yal enquête
avec des cérémonies avec le premier
année premier anniversaire deuxième
anniversaire troisième anniversaire etc
il ya ensuite le procès quand il a lieu
encore une fois rappelons que le procès
est rare vous allez faire le terrorisme
mais celui-là était exemplaire à tous
niveaux
et ensuite il ya le retour à la vie
normale qui peut commencer avant le
procès mais où pas un mais qui veut dire
qu on redevient citoyens attireront
restent victimes du terrorisme c'est un
statut qu'on a mais ça nous définit pas
en redevient citoyens et pour réduire sa
citoyenneté ça veut dire qu'on de
revient acteurs de la société à dire
qu'on retrouve un travail qu'on a une
interaction avec les autres etc et
différentes étapes là il y as haut-fond
des dispositifs les interlocuteurs qui
sont là haut niveau de l'état et des
associations c'est oui c'est ça c'est ce
qu'on a mis en place quand je suis
arrivé en fait on a créé le service
public de l'aide aux victimes en gros
c'est une espèce de clichés uniques
c'est l'état qu'il incarne avec les
associations évidemment où la victime
vient ya un numéro de téléphone ya un
site internet il ya des interlocuteurs
physique et elle est d'abord écouté
entendu et puis elle est orientée il
faut vous dire que quand on a vécu ce
type de traumatisme le la vie
administrative est compliquée par
exemple vous devez retrouver un emploi
vous êtes hélas parfois handicapés donc
votre vie change il faut que vous alliez
en mdph c'était maison du handicap qui
sont un peu compliqué sur le plan
administratif
vous avez des interlocuteurs à la
sécurité sociale parce qu'il faut qu'on
prenne en charge vos frais il faut aussi
qu'on vrai manage votre logement parce
que vous pouvez plus habiter dans le
même logement bien souvent hélas vous
avez des difficultés
personnelles matrimonial ou qu'il peut y
avoir des divorces je ne parle même pas
des difficultés économiques du
changement d'emploi bref le
bouleversement est telle que ce qu'on a
mis en place c'est une protection un
accompagnement individualisé et l'état
est l'interlocuteur et ensuite ils
organisent les choses avec une larve ou
à vélo dire si cet accompagnement et
perd ainsi les moyens sont sont toujours
là et je voudrais qu'on les entende ses
victimes qui ont traversé l'épreuve de
ce procès on voit cela avec eux les eaux
sont
plus de 2500 partie civile pour ce
procès hors norme et une interminable
plongée dans les coulisses d'une tuerie
sans précédent
le l'idée c'est d'en attendre le moins
possible que simplement on arrive à
remettre de la dignité de l'humanité est
un petit peu de hauteur de vue dont ce
qui va être le procès d'un des crimes
les plus abominables que nous ayons
connue en france par les témoigner le
procès est aussi l'occasion pour les
victimes ou les proches de disparus de
s'exprimer face au box des accusés c'est
mon moment face et le moment pour ma
fille c'est pas le moment les accusés
pour n'importe qui soit là kg compte ou
pas toutes façons peu m'importe moi je
veux évoquer claire et
et puis dire aussi ce que j'ai vécu et
puis
ce
que je vis maintenant aussi sur ma fille
qui était mon enfant unique mais voilà
quatre mois après le début du procès
place aux accusés et à l'unique membres
encore vivants de signes et recommande
aux salles abdeslam celui qui le premier
jour affirmé être un combattant de
l'état islamique entamer lentement sa
mue et de neuvre il a assumé de ce
défilé surtout c'est ça qui est vraiment
extrêmement à mon sens blessant pour les
victimes qui viennent entendre quelque
chose on va dire à la fois je suis un
combattant du jihad je suis un
combattant du combattant du califat
j'assume et se défiler sur toutes les
questions l'accusé fini par présenter un
nouveau visage il abandonne la
provocation explique avoir renoncé par
humanité a actionné sa ceinture
d'explosifs et finit par présenter ses
excuses aux victimes
je pense que c'est une version qui lui
permet de dire qu' il n'a jamais rien
fait qui l'a jamais voulu faire de mal à
personne et qu'une adhésion à l'état
islamique mecs est en aucun cas le
guerrier de l'état islamique tel qui
s'était présenté le premier jour le
problème c'est que l'effet colle pas du
tout avec ça puis vient l'heure des
réquisitions
difficile alors pour les victimes et
leurs proches de se contenter des peines
qui pourraient être prononcés forcément
sera jamais satisfait regard des faits
qui ont été perpétrés regard de la
souffrance que a enduré mon frère enduré
sa femme qu'il endure encore
actuellement le killer duras qui portera
ce fardeau toute sa vie pour moi ça
restera forcément toujours léger étant
donné que fut la soeur d'une des
victimes directes
de ces de ces attentats
148 jours d'audience sur plus de 10 - et
pour les parties civiles la crainte de
l'après entre soulagement et peur du
vide
juliette médaille tout le monde
s'accorde à dire ok ce procès est un
très grand moment de justice même de
démocratie à l'heure où on a
l'impression que nos institutions
vacille un peu même certaines victimes
disent qu'elles ont confiance dans la
justice n'est pas rien quand on a été
victime je rappelle que voilà nous
sommes en direct on n'a pas encore le
verdict et et le président de la cour
d'assises spéciale est en train de lire
sont son jugement dont on ne sait pas
encore qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
marqué je crois savoir que vous êtes
vous êtes allé à l'audience oui je suis
allé à plusieurs plusieurs journées de
l'audience d'abord la salle superbe il
faut quand même le souligner c'est dans
la salle des pas perdus du ministère de
la justice et qui a été construite de
toutes pièces une immense salle
d'audience pour accueillir ces 2500
parties civiles les avocats la presse et
c'est donc des moyens qui ont été mis et
la salle a été bien conçu bien
construite pour qui et de la sérénité et
ça c'est très important sur un procès
sur une un drame à vif
la chancellerie a réussi et le président
période a réussi à amener de la sérénité
et à amener de l'émotion tout en maniant
l'humour c'est à dire qu'il y avait de
la tension dans les premières journées
et à plusieurs moments avec beaucoup de
délicatesse il réussissait même en
interrogeant salle abdeslam je l' ai vu
faire avoir quand même un petit recul en
montrant qu'il n'était pas complètement
dupe de ce que raconte et salades
d'islam donc ça a été un procès
remarquablement organisée avec un
personnel judiciaire très compétents les
trois avocats généraux le président
périès et puis j'ai trois souligné quand
même que les victimes ont impressionné
comme toujours par leur maturité je n'en
n'ai entendu aucune me dire j'attends
vengeance en fait tout vous disent
aujourd'hui nous attendons justice et
nous attendons la vérité et 16e denoix
de saint marc c'est le moment du verdict
quand on est victime soient même du du
terrorisme comment on l'appréhendent est
ce qu'on trouve l'apaisement une fois au
fond le jugement tombé alors
l'apaisement commence déjà par les
débats et parlent tous travaillé
préliminaire qui est fait et tout le
travail qu'on avait fait en amont qui
permet justement assez justice de paris
v comme une boule de vengeance de nc
terre et sont arrivés sereine consciente
des faits elles sont arrivés parce
qu'elle était accompagnée de façon
pluridisciplinaire etc consciente des
enjeux s'était préparé à ce procès et se
sont très bien comportés et nous ont
même fait des cadeaux magnifique par le
témoignage qu'elles ont apporté des
témoignages d'humanité des témoignages
de deux voix les droits de l'homme était
incarnée par ses victimes ce
contrat elles ont été des professeurs de
ce que c'est que la justice alors que
très souvent on à la caricature de la
victime perd plus de haine de vengeance
et qu'on doit calmer et dans non elles
ont été une hauteur de vue qui était
fantastique
ce qui a amené du coup en miroir les
auteurs a aussi se calquer là dessus est
ce qui a amené des débats s'est retendu
mais globalement serait roule à
l'humanité ressortait et ce travail là
ça prouve qu'on peut faire même dans des
procès comme ça on peut rendre justice
de façon sereine et contrairement à ce
qu'on croit les victimes peuvent
contribuer par leur attitude à ce que
les débats soient sereins car c'est très
clairement la parole de ses victimes qui
restera le grand temps fort de ce procès
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
améliorer les choses aujourd'hui pour
les pour les accompagner au mieux qu'est
ce qui reste à faire il reste à remettre
en place un service public de l'aide aux
victimes avec une direction politique
parce que en fait si vous voulez c'est
un peu technique mais il ya plein de
ministères concernés sur les victimes y
a pas que le ministère de la justice il
ya le ministère de la santé il ya le
ministère des finances
d'ailleurs on revient à cette histoire
de guichet unique ce qui nous a beaucoup
aidé c'est que l'on n'ait pas besoin de
ré expliquer son histoire avec 6000
guichet
n'existe plus moi je voulais éviter le
jeu comme je disais toujours d'ajouter
de la douleur halal ou de la douleur je
voulais éviter le parcours du tout
l'effet primes administratif bas il est
de luzon délégation est l'une des
licences délégation interministérielle
qui est un peu qui en fait technique une
un service mais qui au lieu d'être
rattaché à matignon c'est à dire auprès
du premier ministre est permettre
l'interministérialité aujourd'hui
rattachée au ministère de la justice
donc qui a perdu en force de frappe et
qui a perdu au rayonnement des quatre
établissements également alors celle là
elle existe mais vrai que ça revienne au
niveau du premier ministre et puis
surtout ce n'est pas une dimension
politique c'est une dimension technique
etc est formidable anja un travail
fantastique qui est fait mais
la voix n'est pas portée au niveau
politique et c'est pour ça que nous
avons besoin d'un secrétaire d'état
pourrait que c'est l'heure du
remaniement bah écoutez croyez vous
croyez pas du tout j'en sais rien je n'y
crois pas du tout de même sens que je
malheureusement je n'y crois pas mais
non j'avais construire en quittant
gouvernement un service interministériel
qui était logé à matignon justement
parce que je me doutais qu'il y aurait
plus de ministère dédié et ce service et
là ça a été détricoté donc il faut c'est
au moins remettre en place un service
interministériel à matignon et puis il
faut qu'il y ait une impulsion politique
où on dise depuis matignon l'aide aux
victimes est importante cette priorité
il ne faut pas abandonner en cours de
route dernière question juliette mais
adel il ya aussi eu des témoignages
importants de hauts représentants du
renseignement
territoriale du renseignement extérieur
et un ancien président de la république
françois hollande qui a également
reconnu une part d'erreur voire même des
chèques dans la politique antiterroriste
était important aussi que cela soit dit
ce qui était important c'était de dire
que comme on le disait toujours à
l'époque et je le disais au gouvernement
à partir du moment où il ya un attentat
c'est que la mission de protection de
l'état a échoué c'est une évidence
personne ne pourra dire le contraire
maintenant les responsables politiques
de l'époque et même d'avant ont tout
fait pour que le système de sécurité
soient présents ont tout fait pour
empêcher cela est bien entendu il n'y a
pas de risque zéro donc il ya évidemment
un sentiment de culpabilité fort mais
aussi et donc un devoir de
reconnaissance de cet échec mais aussi
le devoir de tout faire pour éviter que
ça et des décisions ont été prises après
les attentats pour renforcer la lutte
contre l'islamisme radical
mais aussi pour renforcer le système de
protection à mode conclut en rappelant
je dirais que l'état n'est jamais
responsable de ce qui s'est passé parce
que le principe même d'un attentat
réussi c'est que le fait qu'elle une
faille qui a été trouvé
après il ya une responsabilité morale
puisque l'état ne doit assistance et
donc eu un échec de cette assistance je
vous interromps un instant puisqu'on
vient de connaître le verdict en tout
cas pour salah abdeslam la perpétuité
incompressible c'est là la plus de peine
est là c'est rarissime c'est la
réquisition me dit on c'est pas le
verdict alors oui on attend qu'ils y
sont alors on attend pardonnez moi je
vous propose de rester avec nous c'est
l'heure d'accueillir merci déjà d'être
venu sur le plateau de lcp on va cuire
noah franchi pour leur parti pris ils
sont de ce soir la sémiologue mariette
darrigrand qui va remonter aux origines
d'un mot plus que jamais dans l'air du
temps ce mot c'est le mot de compromis
et puis le grand reporter vincent hugeux
qui va revenir sur ce nouveau témoignage
accablant au congrès américain contre
donald trump sur l' attaque du capitole
nos a franchi les voici bonsoir à vous
de mariette on l'a dit on l'a beaucoup
le commenter ici on est entré dans
l'inconnu situation inédite sous la vème
république on utilise des mots d'un pass
parlementaire la france serait
ingouvernable vous vous levez vous
vouliez revenir comme sémiologue ce soir
sur un autre mot celui dont on a besoin
le mot de compromis non oui parce que
c'est un mot qu'on prononce beaucoup
mais alors qui est très très mal aimé je
crois d'ailleurs que c'est lui le grand
inconnu de la faire en ce moment parce
que évidemment c'est facile à comprendre
tout le monde a l'impression de très
très bien qu'on pense ce mot compromis
etc mais en fait je crois qu'on le
connaît très mal très mal alors déjà on
commence par le confondre avec
compromissions et là évidemment ça le
rend très très négatif alors on y va on
va le disséquer avec votre mot de
compromis voilà dans ces cas là bas il
n'ya pas il n'y avait pas d'autre
solution que de n'être voilà au scalpel
et puis regardez son étymologie d'où il
vient qu'est-ce qu'il dit au départ
alors dans ce cas là bas on coupe kum
vous savez en atteint c'est toujours les
mots en conversation communication en
collaboration coopération c'est le avec
du latin donc ça ça commence plutôt bien
et c'est ensuite le premier là qui nous
pose problème mais le mot il faut
revenir aux verts blancs m'intéresse
c'est sa première et ça veut dire
envoyer vers quelque chose donc il faut
se représenter l'image on a deux
personnes qui vont l'une vers l'autre
vous si vous achetez une maison mais
compromis de vente ça gêne personne ces
deux personnes qui vont l'une vers
l'autre et puis il y a un objet entre
les deux alors j'insiste un tout petit
peu sur le côté deal négociations parce
qu'en france ça nous amène des
connotations plutôt négative dans les
pays protestants c'est beaucoup plus
léger ça donc voilà donc la culture pèse
aussi sûr sur ça mais si je vous donne
là l'expression latine total il ya un
troisième larron qui vient dans la scène
celle arbitres parce que l'expression et
le comme promis terreau est un hymne
arbitre sommes donc il y à l' arbitre il
ya un tiers qui arrive entre les deux
personnes et c'est ce tiers qui
m'intéresse alors c'est qui ce tiers ça
peut être le 49-3 voilà ça c'est le
critère un peu tranchant voilà c'est le
tiers si j'ose dire de l'état qui vient
et qui tranche et le grand papa de
l'état qui transmet là ce sera plus le
cas où peut-être une fois par par
période ça n'ira pas donc je crois que
c'est cette question qui est très
intéressante sur le plan politique c'est
qu'il faut que le tiers viennent des
députés eux mêmes viennent du des bancs
des députés il faut pas attendre que ce
soit où l'état où la loi ou la justice
non il va falloir faire oeuvre
d'imagination
donc si je prends un exemple comparé m
même voilà qui s'auto arbitres mais en
ouvrant une fenêtre prenons la question
du smic à 1500 euros alors on va avoir
le deuil il y aura les pour et y aura
les comptes qui vont ce vraiment être en
opposition peut-être en égaux mais alors
du genre
1352 et c'est ça c'est ça va pas quand
on fait comme ça en revanche si on
regarde la société et si on a une idée
une troisième dimension mais sociétal je
prends on n'y connaissant rien là je
veux dire travail politique mais moi je
regarde la société je sais qu'il y à ce
qu'on appelle la santé mentale des
jeunes c'est un problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui donc mettons pourrait
dire ballet 1500 ok mais que pour les
moins de 28 ans on est moins de 30 ans
c'est ça que je veux dire par arbitres
par tiens voilà alors évidemment c'est
là où c'est intéressant c'est que vous
connaissez l'expression à mettre
l'imagination au pouvoir ce qu'il faut
de l'imagination pour faire c'est plus
urgent que jamais je suis pour qu'on
mette l'imagination au perchoir est là
mais très intéressant sémiologue
mariette darrigrand merci beaucoup
compromis on plonge comme chaque semaine
dans l'étymologie les origines
l'itinéraire d'un mot dans l'actualité
donald trump un putschiste en liberté
c'est ce que vous nous dites ce soir
vincent et jeu et oui alors elle se
nomme cassidy atkinson cette brune de 26
ans était sous donald trump l'assistante
du chef de cabinet du tombeur de hillary
clinton non sans bravoure cassis qui a
témoigné hier devant la commission
parlementaire appelé à établir si oui ou
non
trump a orchestré une tentative de coup
d'état le 6 janvier 2021 date funeste ce
jour là c'est le jour où le vice
président mike pence doit certifier le
résultat du scrutin fatal aux machos
peroxydée donc la victoire du vieux
démocrate joe biden mais c'est aussi et
surtout le jour où la démocratie
américaine va si ce mercredi au détour
d'une harangue décousu trump hurlent à
la fraude et incite ses partisans à
déferler sur le capitole siège du
congrès alors que révèle de nouveaux la
petite main de la maison blanche aussi
sobre qu'accablant les confidences de
miss atkinson parachève le récit d'un
épisode que le scénariste netflix le
plus déjanté n'aurait osé imaginer on
apprend ainsi que donne le dingue a
tenté de rejoindre ses disciples
déchaîné à l'heure de l'assaut que vaut
si fertile à l'adresse du policier du
secretservice alors au volant de sa
limousine éloignez les enfants du post
je suis le de président
conduisait mois au capitole tout de
suite
et le sortant sorti et s'est même de
s'emparer par la force du volant de la
bagnole blindés quand sa protection
rapprochée invoque des impératifs de
sécurité soulignant que certains
assaillants sont armés voici ce que
réplique trump l'idole du lobby de la
gâchette je n'en ai rien à ils ne
sont pas là pour me faire mal en quoi
ces anecdotes éclaire le mal qui ronge
la société américaine ont bien sûr on se
doutait que le locataire du bureau ovale
ne tournait pas rond bien sûr on le
savait irascible paranoïaque menteur
raciste misogyne homophobe inculte et
vénale mais là n'est pas le pire le pire
c'est qu'en cas de victoire des
républicains lors des législatives de mi
mandat en novembre prochain la
commission denquête sera dissoute et ses
travaux un millier de témoins entendus
140 mille documents épluché enterré sans
autre forme de procès le pire c'est que
dans ce cas trump le putschiste pourrait
briguer un nouveau mandat en 2024 le
pire enfin c'est qu'un tiers des
électeurs américains croit encore dur
comme fer qu'on a volé sa victoire au
gourou de la secte une secte de 25 à 30
millions d'adeptes quand même mais allez
savoir peut-être les états unis phare
supposée du monde libre s'affranchit en
compte il attend d'un tel sortilèges
peut-être on peut rêver la justice
envers attelle l'ancien pirate de
l'immobilier mediterra l'ombre cette
maxime latine on n'en sort pas arc star
paya capitoli proxima la roche
tarpéienne est proche du capitole merci
infiniment pour ce parti pris et merci
pour voilà cet avertissement on va voir
quel sera l'avenir de donald trump donc
vous nous dites ce soir quand tous les
cas il reste totalement politique merci
à vous juliette bea d'elle merci à vous
guillaume denoix de saint-marc c'est la
fin de cette émission merci mariette
bien évidemment merci à vous d'avoir
suivi tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire ce soir un film de nicolas
bourgoin et mélissa theuriau mon enfant
chéri sur l'addiction des jeunes à la
drogue très belle soirée
[Musique]